mais tout coup il a de PO de mes ah
tiens a pesur tout c'est gr àause
de PE de rien toutis pas il pas'ffronter
ttter
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Ilie c'est vrai que j'ai ouvert un salon
de coiffure qui s'appelle Factory 6
Saint Marcel vas-y vas-y pas pas la Prom
bring aussi non mais voilà j'étais en
train de j'étais en train de me faire
couper les cheveux tranquillement avec
mon employé et le et le poteau à mon
employé tout simplement et là j'ai deux
individus qui rentrent dans le salon et
pour l'anecdote en fait ce qui est ce
qui est ce qui est moi j'ai senti direct
l'ambi arrivrié et et mon employé en
fait quand il les a vu rentrer déjà il
leur a dit le salon est fermé ouais mais
quand ils arrivent avec un bonnet une
écharpe c'est compliqué de dire que le
salon est fermé
et du coup ils sont arrivés ben j'ai
rien compris à ce qui s'est passé tout
simplement il sont direct allé voir mon
employé il y en a un qui a sorti la gaz
la Crimo ouais l'autre il est arrivé il
a sorti un couteau moi j'ai strictement
rien compris ce qui se passait surtout
que mon salon en plus il y a des caméras
is donc c'est filmé et là direct direct
il a pris le poteau à mon employé donc
mon employé s fait gazer pour rien le
pote à mon employé il s'est fait gazer
il lui a pris ça sa coche moi il est
venu directement vers moi avec le
couteau en me disant donne moi ton T Max
ah ouaisoi mais moi bien sûr que je B
tiens prends le Tmax prends-le le T Max
tiens je te le donne je pas me prendre
un coup de couteau donc du coup je lui
ai donné le tmaxou mais en fait le truc
c'est que ben en fait je me suis protégé
moi auparavant et j'ai mis des des
traceeurs en fait sur mon sur mon sur
mon Tmax du coup donc du coup il est
parti avec le Tmax et en fait c'est ça
qui m'a rassuré dans le sens où c'est
pour ça que je peux en parler maintenant
c'est que je savais où il allait mon
Tmax et je remercie encore la police
parce qu'ils ont fait vraiment un
travail vraim vraiment au top du top
c'est-à-dire que comme ils ont pris le
Tmax en fait je pense que allez 1 heure
après ils les ont interpellé directement
savais qu' tétait ou pas pardon tu
savais qui tu était ou pas du tout je
pense que oui oui pourquoi tu tu t'as
senti comment comment tu l'as senti
parce que je l'ai senti il a été très
surpris en fait toi tu t'as vu ah ouais
ouais ouais très surpris très en fait
j'y vais j'y vais pas en fait il a été
choqué et même sa réaction elle a été
elle a été même choquée et je pense
qu'il s'attendait pas en fait à me voir
tout simplement et je pense que c'est
même pour ça qu'il a été et ben grâce à
ma à ma notoriété on va dire entre
guillemets ben je pense que peut-être ça
m'a sauvé la vie parce que il m'a pas
gazé il m'a rien fait à moi ouais tuas
il a gazé mon employé alors que mais je
me suis j'ai eu peur j'ai j'ai vu ma vie
défiler presque parce que s'il me mets
un coup de couteau comment je fais moi
après je fais quoi après dans ma vie je
fais rien du tout surtout que je devais
monter aujourd'hui parce que j'avais
j'avais un shooting photo très très
important ouais ça aurait été relou et
j'ai pas envie de me prendre moi je lui
donne le T Max après il m'a demandé les
montres tellement j'ai même pas de Mont
j'ai plus rien je mets plus de bijoux je
mets je mets rien du tout oui j'ai mis
mon bijou béb parce que voilà ça c'estqu
pas voilà
mais mais du coup non mais j'ai j'ai
voilà j'ai j'ai très peur voilà j'ai
très très peur surtout que en plus moi
je suis un garçon qui aime la France
j'aime la France je suis français j'aime
Marseille j'aime ma ville moi je suis
parti pour tu trouves tu trouves que tu
es plus en sécurité en France c'est pas
après c'est pas moi de dire ça c'est pas
à moi de dire si on est en sécurité ou
on est pas en sécurité je n'ai pas je
n'ai pas les les connaissances pour dire
ça si je dirais quelque chose c'est que
peut-être il il manque de sécurité mais
après dire le mot on est plus en
sécurité' faitquer tu t'es fait braquer
tr fois toi trois fois ouais trois fois
ouais moi j'ai vraiment le record hein
franchement niveau record on est
Fran premier braquage c'est c'était il y
a 3 ans 4 ans céta avec mon ex ouais
carrément ils sont rentrés chez moi
ouais ils sont rentrés chez moi et
tellement et à l'époque moi j'habitais
avec paga ouais d'accord tu connais très
bien je pense ouiad et et j'habite avec
lui et tellement que moi dans ma tête je
me disais mais c'est mon collègue qui
rentre en fait et j'ai même pas calculé
donc je me suis remis sur sur l'autre
côté sauf que une minute après ah mais
j'ai rien compris ou je me suis réveillé
j'avais euh euh une main gant là et un
calibre là ouais tellement je l'ai
regardé mais j'ai frère carrément c'est
GTA GTA carrément comme comme dans les
films comme dans les films maintenant je
peux en parler parce que ça fait un
moment et je suis content et je suis
fier d'en parler pas je suis fier dans
le sens et c'était quoi la deuxième fois
la deuxième fois si je sortais de chez
moi ouais il était quoi 13h 13h de
l'après-midi 14h je sors ouais j'allais
chez mon collègue je sors tranquille de
chez moi je fais mes courses au casino
comme comme une personne lambda en fait
je vis parce qu'à un moment donné
peut-être je suis connu peut-être j'ai
la notoriété mais un moment donné je je
veux vivre je suis pas un robot donc je
veux vivre je veux faire mes courses
comme tout le monde moi j'aime faire ça
en fait et le problème c'est que j'ai
pris mon j'ai pris mon scooter ils m'ont
coupé la route carrément ils sont sortis
calibrés et là ils m'ont demandé la mre
arrê
max non non mais non mais ce qu'on
disait c'est mais c'est même pas la
question de pas de chance ou pas c'est
qu'à un moment donné à un moment donné
je moi je veux rester en France sinon la
solution c'est quoi je pars à l'étranger
mais le problème c'est que moi ma ma vie
elle est en France ma vie elle est à
Marseille 2è ville de France on a euh
même la France pour moi la France c'est
la France frère pourant j'ai vécu he
j'ai vécu j'ai vécu à Dubaï je suis
resté 6 mois à Dubaï mais c'est pas
quelque chose qui me PLA mais maintenant
en en France tu tu tuas tu as une
appréhension quand tu sors quand tu ah
complètement V ah ouais ah ouais
complètement c'est-à-dire moi maintenant
quand je sors je vois un mec qui a qui a
un casque intégral ou qui a qui a des
gants ou qui a des trucs ou quoi et ben
j'ai peur je regarde je regarde mon
rétro j'essaie de de d'essayer de de
contrôler parce que j'ai très très peur
ouais ouais ouais j'ai très très peur je
suis allé même voir un psychologue par
rapport à à ça et M mon PSI moi il
m'avait dit hein Clément Luc je te salue
d'ailleurs euh mon PSI me l'avait dit il
m'avait dit dans tout drama essaie de de
voir le côté positif mais quand tu as
des trucs comme ça le côté positif il
est compliqué moi je sais quand ils sont
rentrés chez moi j'arrivais plus à
dormir dans ma chambre je dormais sur le
fauteuil sur le fauteuil de chez moi et
je regardais la porte d'entrée et à
chaque bruit en fait je je levais la
tête pour voir s'il y avait quelqu'un
pour voir si si ah c'est normal c'est
c'est moi pour moi c'est tu dis tu dis
qu'il y a beaucoup de stars de télarité
qui partent de France aussi parce
qu'elles sentent plus en en en sécurité
ici
je pense que elles partent parce qu'ils
ont ils ont surtout des enfants je pense
aussi c'est pour je pense aussi pour
leurs enfants ouais quoi elles ont peur
pour leurs enfants je pense aussi qu'ils
ont très très peur pour leurs enfants
parce qu'à un moment donné on vit dans
un monde ok d'accord si on est dans un
bon monde mais moi je trouve qu'on est
dans un monde quand même qui est
compliqué voilà je l'ai pas après c'est
pas moi de juger mais moi je trouve
qu'on est dans un monde qui est
compliqué parce que parce que moi je
fais je fais un métier la chance j'ai la
chance de faire un métier que j'aime
c'est-à-dire moi mon mon but c'est de
divertir les gens d'amuser les gens
de faire des blagues mais quand on a des
actions comme ça j'ai plus envie de rien
faireors alors Coraline qui est avec
nous éit venue nous raconter le terrible
cage don été victime quelques mois plus
tôt Coraline é en train de se filmer
pour les réseaux quand les cambrioleurs
sont arrivés
[Musique]
regardez
[Applaudissements]
alors merci Coraline d'être avec nous
donc un homme s à votre porte vous
agresse violemment rappelez-nous ce qui
s'est passé ouais en fait c'est un un
jeune homme qui a sonné à la porte
j'avais le judas j'ai regardé un jeune
homme donc je me suis dit bon ok j'ai
ouvert il m'a dit que céit un de mes
voisins je ne les connais pas tous donc
j'ai ouvert la porte m'a demandé de
l'aluminium euh je suis allé cherch l'UM
l'aluminium dans la cuisine et en fait
quand j'ai pris l'aluminium j'ai senti
qu'il y a quelque chose qui était pas
normal et en venant sur mes pas il
m'attendait dans le salon il m'a pris à
la gorge et la Essen en il m'a tabassé
pour que je tombe déjà et puis il m'a il
voulait ma montre
alors là il dévalise il vous ont
dévalisé dévalise V votre dressing c'est
ça ouais en fait il cherche ma montre
dans mon dressing était devant ses yeux
et il l'a même pas vu et puis d'un
moment je leur dis mais qu'est-ce que
vous voulez je suis all leur chercher ma
mon je leur ai donné main dans la main
ils ont pris mon portable qui était en
train de tourner ils sont partis en me
fermant dans le dans le dressing alors
vous avez des des affaires assez de
grandes marques dans votre dressing ou
pas mais pas forcément en vous les
montrer sur TikTok c'est peut-être pour
ça qu'il est venu aussi est-ce que c'est
sur insta plus que que mais oui non je
j'ai pas beaucoup de choses enfin j'ai
des choses que j'aime bien mais c'est
pas des
choses si luxux que ça c'est peut-être
des trucs de marque et estce qui c'est
pas c'est pas vos vidéos qui ont fait
que les personnes son ouais je pense que
c'est bien mon compte Instagram à mon
avis que la montre je la portais depuis
presque 10 ans en fait donc je faisais
pas attention
d'accord aujourd'hui c'est vrai que on
en parlait il a un instant avec Greg
est-ce que aujourd'hui vous êtes vous
êtes traumatisé par ce qui s'est passé
est-ce que vous videz bien sûr B c'est
la même chose moi dès que j'ai quelqu'un
qui me suit dans la rue cagoule ou pas c
enfin casque ou pas casque enfin
n'importe quel personne j'ai peur tous
les hommes alors on a l'impression
Michel parce que c'est vrai que il est
21h5 il y a beaucoup beaucoup de gens
qui réagissent sur cette séquence les
vols à main armé se multiplie de fou en
ce moment et donc justement pour les
téléspectateurs qui nous regardent c'est
c'est incroyable oui il y a une recrue
des s de ce type de criminalité là
depuis quelques mois je vis juste faire
une une toute petite observation sur les
les deux les deux situations dans
lesquell auxquelles vous avez été
confrontés je pense qu'à chaque fois ils
ont été repérés vous c'est le Tmax alors
pardon excusez-moi je vous coupe
attendez je vous coupe 30 secondes je ne
fais plus de story moi c'est-à-dire
maintenant où je vais non mais je vous
parle pas de vous je vous parle de votre
scooter oui mais mon
SC les Tmax c'est l'engin le plus volé
je suis d'accord avec vous un repérage
c'est pas vous qui cherchez c'est votre
scooter et après ils ont vu que c'était
vous vouis juste il y a pas de souci
mais mon scooter mon scooter attendez je
vous coupe 30 secondes mon scooter ok
d'accord il est volé mais c'est un
scooter que j'ai acheté d'occasion il
est même pas
neuf aprèon vous a vu avec c'est tout
vous a repéré avec le scooter et ils
sont ven chercheravir le scooterér avec
le scooter en fait et en fait ce qui se
passe c'est qu'près ils ont été étonnés
que ce soit lui à tu vois c'est ça c'est
exactement ça et et vous effectivement
c'est à peu près pareil vous avez été vu
avec cette montre sur les réseaux et ils
sont venus ils vous ont identifié loger
et ils sont venus
vous et pour revenir à la base du du de
de l'émission d'hier que j'ai vu dont
j'ai vu toute la séquence en intégralité
en fait c'est ce que Géraldine sait
faire de mieux c'est-à-dire détourner
non mais il faut rendre à César voilà
Cyril parlait des gens qui se poser des
questions on est revenu sur le concept
général du fait d'avoir traité tout le
monde d'antivax d'avoir criminé d'avoir
passé des mesures autoritaires et
coercitives et qu'est-ce que tu fais en
fait tu arrives et tu focalises sur une
ultra ultra minorité pour dénigrer pour
mettre des étiquettes infamantes sur la
totalité et par
association sensurer je voudrais juste
aller au
bout par disqualification et par
association diffamante et ça c'est ta
technique préférée monsieur nollo aussi
alors que pour
voant ça vous plaît ben vous aimez faire
aux autres ce que vous n'aimez pas qu'on
vous fasse déjà c'est un problème
ensuite tous les deux vous prenez pour
des grands experts mais on a
précédemment que vous êtes en fait vous
n'y connaissez rien vous désinformez
comme sur la Suède vous avez affirmé
mordicus tous les
deux pouruc plus Personen
pour déteste la mavaise FO rien à avec
Leon tout moi je n'ai jamais donné un
conseil médical sur ce plateau
JIS
mé moi je tu sais ce que c'est mon
combat c'est la liberté de choisir pour
son propre cor comme pour l'avortement
là mais tout d'un coup il y a deux POS
de mesure ah tiens il est il a peur
Monsieur Tout gr
àa a peur il a peur de rien du tout je
sais pas il aime pas m'affronter
apparment sur Twitter il prend desac à
chaqueis
m'enie j'ai pas peur vous nêtes pas
très non mais je ne tape pas moi je suis
je pas m' n'avais plus la
parole PvZ m'rter en face
face il pas peur de toi c'est un pote en
plus c'est un pote je permets de lui
dire des
trucsement s'adore j'ai pas envie qu'on
s'embrouille pour Ren par qu'on
[Rires]
s'imeoule con Eric Eric ilaffronte qui
tu veux Eric il s'en fout complètement
d'affronter des gens alors je vais te
dire c'est juste que là il sait queon va
l' aller s'embrouiller comme on est très
potte on n pas envie de s'embrouiller
pour rien bravo Eric Eric je t'invite à
dîner du coup vous voulez que je fasse
la même chose toi tu je m'en fous tu es
payé tu es
payé non donc en fait pour moi tu as été
trop loin et je te le dis vraiment
calmement je trouve vraiment que ça
banalise l'antisémitisme en plus c'est
contreproductif à force de crier au loup
toute la journée un tel un tel et
homophobe un tel antisémite tu dacr
paralise ces sujets là c'est extrêmement
grave et vu l'état de tension qu'il y a
dans le pays actuellement je trouve que
c'est totalement irresponsable et ça m'a
mise vraiment en colère parce que moi j
étais à ces manifestations moi j'é'ai
pas vu là-bas et vraiment il y a des
gens qui m'ont bouleversé il y avait un
monsieur qui il y a plein de gens il y a
a des gens qui parlaient de suicide les
gens ils aimaient aller ces
manifestations parce qu'ils étaient
discriminés ils n'avaient plus accès à
rien il faut le comprendre et ils
aimaient se retrouver il y avait moi
j'ai pas vu une seule de ces pancardes
je les ai vu dans des articles de
journaux je sais pas où ils ont pris ces
photos elles sont vraies et ça existe et
il faut pas le nier non plus mais c'est
une ultra minorité et de jeter l'eau
prore sur des milliers de gens qui était
à C manifestation et des millions de
gens dans le pays qui juste voulaient
avoir le droit au consentement le droit
au consentement geréraldine c'est pas
rien c'est la base des démocraties ok de
le droit au consentement pour son propre
corps et hier quand tu as parlé
d'antisémitisme pour moi tu as été trop
loin tu as insulté ces gens tu as
insulté les gamins qui étaient à partir
de 12 ans discriminés dit d'avoir des
activités extrcolaires à 12 ans alors
qu'il n'était pas à risque des trucs de
fou mon fils il fait
du les mecux qui disent des conneries
pareil en Suède il y avait un pass je
suis désolé il y avait un pass
pour quoi il y avait pas de passe pour
les enfants de pass pour aller
travailler donc Valérie benim aussi
Valérie du Pomet c'est bon vous pouvez
lui répondre non mais c'est bon tu
rejoindre tu vas rejoindre qui tu vas
croiser en coulisseam Palomba
donc non encore une fois Béatrice je
n'ai pas du tout essentialisé ou
généralisé je je vraiment je t'assure je
te demande de regarder si tu plusieurs
fois parce que le clip a tourner
beaucoup et juste que je voudrais
rajouter c'est ce que tu fais à chaque
fois Géraldine sur les gilets jaunes tu
as fait ça tu as fait ça dès que ça va à
l'encontre pourquoi ça vous pose un
problème de dire que c'est une réalité
pourquoi de dire que quand il y a
quelque chose qu'on ne comprend pas je
c'est moi qui te l'ai dit ça existe mais
pourquoi de dire dire que c'est juste
une minorité ultra minorité je les ai
même pas vu donc je dis que ça existe
parce que j'ai V des pH all je peux te
dire que dans les post dans les posts
sur la pandémie il y a eu des centaines
de milliers de likes de commentaires
absolument immondes la vierie le covid
Busin nous a empoisonné Buin la
sal des milliers des milliers pas des
minorités minor quand là à cette place
là et qui il a eu des propos que moi
j'ai trouvé antisémite contre ellizabeth
Levi tu n'as rien dit tu as une
indignation à géométrie variable quand
il a dit à Élizabeth Lévi vous ça vous
dit quelque chose d'ACh ça chose
qu chose le courage de dire quel chose
il pour qu' fait une
bnemission je vi dire j'é choqué ce que
tu as
hieré pars
detisam été choqué par les propos soir
dans oui
à 24% c'est une large majorité quand
même qui a été choqué voilà voilà merci
Merci à VOUS est-ce que les chroniqueurs
ont été choqués puisqu'ils ont assisté à
l'émission oui il y en a oui Gill verdz
oui extrêmement choqué j'adore et moi je
suis toujours d'accord avec G Veron Gill
Verdez depuis qu'il a pris la galette
avec vous c'est devenu un agneau de lait
donc pas du tout j'ai défoncé il y a 2
minutes l'émission quoi g je suis
complètement d'accord avec toi elle est
jalouse la
maillet c'est pas c'est pas après que
moi ça déconne je me dis que ça déconne
de rembourser 31000 € qu'on lui
rembourse ok pas de problème mais on
rembourse pas d'autres choses il y a
d'autres choses qui sont pas remboursées
on voit des gens dans la rue il y a les
S François Holland les avait appelé les
sents par exemple il y a des gens qui on
travaill toute leur vie on le rembourse
pas leurs dents à eux et pourtant c'est
pour s'alimenter les dents donc c'est
aussi un problème
esétiqueim mais c'est ce que jeis en
train d'qu non l' nempêche pas l'autre
sauf que sauf que si on rembourse 300 on
fait aussi pour
l'autre
besever c'est ce que je suis en
trpendant moi moi ce que j'entends c'est
que on on donne tout le temps aux gens
et je parle pas pour elle on on a
souvent tendance à donner aux gens qui
ne travaillent pas qui ne montrent pas
de bons messages et on sacrifie toujours
les gens qui bossent quelqu'un qui bosse
qui doit se faire remborser ses frais
médicaux on lui dit si tu as pas de
mutuel c'est mort pour imagin avec 8
milliard tu imagines avec 8 milliard de
frudon pas d'autre sujet que de
s'attaquer aux personnes je m'
pas je m'attaque pas à elle de la
question des 30000 € si on me demande
est-ce que est-ce que vous êtes choqué
je dis oui la polémique je la comprends
c'est une polémique est-ce que tu dois
comprendre la polémique je la comprends
parce que tu as des gens en France il
peuvent pas soigner parce qu'ils ont des
problèmes de reins des problèmes de dos
des problèmes de jambes ils vont
travailler en boitant ils vont
travailler sans dents il y en a qui s
les S D c'est 900 pourire qu' fait laiss
Laever aussi les personnes trans je dis
pas qu'on
laisseeverèm train de me faire un truc
tu parles de prostitution prenons les
problèmes dans l'ordre je ne dis pas
qu'il faut pas rembourser son
intervention je dis que avant tout
quelquun qui travaille pour la France
quelqu'un qui donne les bons messages
pour la France et Nina qui Ta aussi des
impôts qui donne les bons messages si on
la rembourse elle 30000 il y a pas de
raison qu'on rembourse pas les aut çais
TR pour ça que je comprends la polémique
non ma je la laisse je la laisse parce
que je comprends la polémique merci
Monsieur le problème enfin quand
j'entends on peut pas rembourser les uns
et ne pas rembourser les autres
excusez-moi on est quand même par parler
de pogon quoi de budget le budget est
pas extensible vous dites qu'on dépense
a 8 milliards de fraudes il y a 800
milliards effectivement de dépenses
sociales mais le problème c'est queon a
encore des besoins on parle de vie on
parle pas de d'gent attendez excusez-moi
c'est pas su ce qu' est en train de dire
c'est que
c'estendez d' d'abord c'est pas vital et
dans ce caslà si vous voulez vous avez
vous avez des non mais attendez vous
avez des gens qui s'ouvrent alors si on
rembourse des dysphories de genre
pourquoi ne rembourson pas des
dysphories chromatiques imaginez par
exemple imaginez qu'un Blanc se sente
noir ou qu'un Noir se sente blanc
pourquoi est-ce qu'on rembourse mais
c'est pas un jugement moral encore une
fois ce n'est pas encore un jugement
moral moi j'ai rien contre vos choix
personnels et votre vie personnelle je
non mais même vos orientations je n'ai
rien contre ça je dis juste quand cont
cont on pe s'interroger juste
Jean-Michel dans un instant vous allez
parlé il m'a dit m' dit un truc de ouf
m' dit mon intervention va faire date
c'est pe-être un peu excessif un
problème qui enfin je vais parler de
choses qui me toucheent voilàc
personnellement d'accord paulski euh
alors moi déjà je tiens à dire que
j'adore la communauté LGBT trans et
cetera je sais que ça doit être super
compliqué de nêtre dans le mauvais corps
mais en fait changeant un peu la vie de
de Raymon du coup il y a plein de gens
qui ont des maladies du coup mortelles
comme le cancer et cetera et eux
ils non il y a plein de gens qui sont
pas remboursés quasiment tous il y a il
y a quand même plein de ch qui sont pas
remboursés et si tu as payé des impôts
si tu as payé des impôts j'aurais aimé
que ce soit remboursé pour pour vous
comme pour les gens qui ont des maladies
par mortelles mais qui à choisir
j'aurais préféré bah payer pour les
mourants mais mais il y a des personnes
parce qu'il faut faire des choix
suicider ou saututiler comme ça ça
aurait été un touttit peu plus j'aimera
j'aimerais Nina et après j'aimerais
Jean-Michel mer par qu'il a dit que ça
allait faire date déjà moi j'ai c'est
pas lanceuse d'alerte moi j'ai fait
cette vidéo déjà c'était pour répondre à
une abonnée pour expliquer et informer
qu'on peut être remboursé par la
Sécurité Sociale et qu'on n pas obligé
en France d'aller se prostituer par
exemple au bois de Boulogne pour payer
ses opérations parce qu'il faut le dire
aussi il y a plein de femmes trans qui
font ça le problème bien évidemment
c'est pas les femmes trans mais c'est
bien le système que qui qui est mal fait
parce que mais moi je suis d'accord he
que c'est pas qu'il y a des inégalités
mais on y est pour rien et ce que je
voulais dire aussi c'est que les
opérations elles sont pas remboursées
automatiquement il y a c'està-dire que
c'est pas on va s'inscrire à l'hôpital
on dit je veux changer de sexe bah
écoutez demain vous aurez une poitrine
c'est pas ça il y a un long parcours il
y a un parcours psychiatrique
psychologique moi entre le moment où je
me suis inscrite et le moment où je me
suis fait opérer de la vaginoplastie
s'est écoulé 8 ans en fait et pendant
les 8 ans j'ai quand même eu les épaules
il y en a elles abandonnent avant elles
se suicid avant il y en a aussi qui
qui qui c'est tellement long le parcours
public pour avoir les opérations
remboursées qu'il y en a qu''s
abandonnent et qui vont payer leurs
opérations en Thaïland ou je ne sais où
mais du coup c'est oui ça peut être
remboursé mais ça se fait pas comme ça
quoi c'est
h y a des gens qui disent il y a des
gens qui disent et voilà c'est ça c'est
la grande question il y a des gens qui
disent le cancer n'est pas un choix par
contre c'est beaucoup moins un choix
c'est ce qu'ils disent c'est ce qu'il
disent sur les réseau Mo personcer
connaissent elles ont été remboursé à
non mais c'est ce dis le concer pas un
choix il y a beaucoup de gens qui disent
que c'est scandaleux sur les réseaux euh
Jean-Michel oui déjà je v dire à Hugo
qui disait que c'était Pinot c'était
tellement peu de personnes c'était pas
important en disant ça éé par 10 le
nombre de personnes qui veulent changer
donc c'est un problème qui prend de
l'ampleur même si c'est encore par 3 moi
je trouve c'est quand même c'est une
question de priorité dans un monde idéal
évidemment que tout quelqu'un qui veut
soit aider pour changer de sexe j'ai
aucun problème sauf qu'il y a des
priorités aujourd'hui les priorités pour
moi elles ne sont pas là j'ai deux
exemples qui ben je vais te dire
pourquoi bien sûr je te dire pourquoi
deux sujets qui m'ont touché
personnellement voilà j'ai grandi à
Épinal mon ami d'enfance bon j'ai trois
amis d'enfance l'un est mort le la nuit
du Nouvel An voilà il a eu fait un
infarctus il appelé les les secours les
secours voulai venir faute de moyens il
y avait pas assez d'ambulance ils ont
fait pas santé il est mort il est décédé
cette nuit-là du 31 décembre voilà ça
m'a beaucoup peiné 5 jours après la mère
de mon deuxème confat d'enfance glisse
sur une plaque de Vergl à Épinal dans
les vuges commotion cérébrale elle
transporte l'hôpital faute de moyens
toujours on l'a fait passer senté sur un
lit dans le couloir de l'hôpital pendant
5h au moment où on fait le le enfin le
scanner il est trop tard pour l'opérer
elle décède 1 heure après donc je suis
désolé donc que les opérations sont
importantes pour vous je suis d'accord
mais il y a des gens qui souffrent
d'Alzheimer ne sont pas remboursés
Alzheimer c'est aussi une priorité pour
les pour beaucoup de familles ça
concerne énormément de g Fr éorme
priorité énormément c'est une très
grosse priorité et deuxièmement
l'argument que c'est très il y a 20 à 40
% des gens qui se font qui changent de
sexe par les les plus jeunes qui veulent
rechanger
il
don
35% et la plupart du temps c'est à cause
de la
pression je dire le gros gros problème
dire le gros gros problème et je le
disant toi n le gros gros problème et je
vois les réactions sur les raisons le le
point névralgique de cette affaire c'est
que pour les
gens il pens que c'est
caprice ils se disent pour eux c'est pas
prioritaire Alzheimer oui c'est
prioritaire en fait c'est ça l'istoire
je te jure c'est pour ça que les gens tu
vas voir le sondage je pense que le
sondageage2%
paschis un
choix pour la plart des gens on peut
voilà aprè je comprends les gens qui
comprennent pas parce qu'il faut
le plus plus personne trans de supporter
les les inégalités en matière de
traitement de santé moi je trouve ça un
peu fort je comprends ton et moi
Jean-Michel mais enfin je veux dire elle
y est absolument pour
rien prends la problématique par ce
côté non mais vous dites que que c'est
pas un choix donc on comprend que c'est
une c'est une maladie ou un trouble mais
le problème c'est que quand on dit que
les transgenres ont une maladie ou un
trouble on dit on les stigmatise donc on
comprend pas très bien en fait soit
c'est une maladie soit c'est une maladie
dans ce cas-là cette maladie doit être
diagnostiquée par un psychiatre donc
vous devez passer chez un psychiatre or
cette or cette
obligation cette obligation non mais en
2023 cette obligation a été levée donc
en fait c'est ça ce que je d'un côté un
côté on tend à normaliser le processus
de changement de genre et en même temps
on rembourse on le rembourse au titre de
la sécurité social donc c'est
contradictoire à côté là s'il vous plaît
regardez je dis je vous dis ce que je
lis non mais c'est bonc je vous dire je
voudrais m'adresser à Nina regardez Nina
il y a beaucoup de de réaction comme
celle que je vais vous dire c'est à
cause de cette femme c'est à cause que
la sécurité sociale ne rembourse pas
assez le reste qu'est-ce que vous
répondez au gens qui disent c'est ça
parce que c'est ça c'est dur à cause de
cette femme
du tout en fait de pointer du Do les
personnes c'est complètement injuste et
juste àtiser la ha ça fait rien d'autre
parce que moi suis pour rien et en plus
comme on disait la transidentité ça
représente un grain de sable dans le
désert c'est ri par
RA pour ça parler
ny la vidéo qu'on a partagé sur les rése
sociaux depuis plusieurs jours à part
pour ratiser la haine c'est pour parce
qu'en fait ça fait c'est pas de la
politique c'est ri tout ça c'est juste
polémique c'est enfin moi j suis
absolument pour rien et et M moi et M
moi je suis la première à dire que oui
il y a des choses qui ne sont pas
normales il y a 30 ans on aurait fait le
même sondage est-ce que c'est un choix
pour l'homosexualité il y aurait eu ça
prend du temps ça va prendre du temps
mais ce qui est bien c'est que tu
continues à essayer et il faut il faut
pas lâcher et des gens comme jeana un
jour peut-être comprendront
que mais pas du tout attendez arrêtez
avec ces bêtises je peux
répondre moi encore une fois je c'est
pas un jugement moral que je porte moi
j'ai rien non moi j'ai j'ai rien j'ai
rien contre vous et et j'ai rien
contreos votre orientation tout ça me
va mais tout ça me va parfaitement moi
j'ai pas de problème avecentation se
REM vous souffrez d'une dysphorie de
genre oui ou
non pas adéquation avec vre avec votre
cor
cérébr ce que je dis c'est que moi ce
que ce qui me Cho mais comme tous les
Français c'est que je suis contribuable
je ne veux pas je ne veux pas que notre
argent serve à ça
excuse jeree je merci Madame merci
Madame ben je un autre tweet en France
on ne rembourse pas les couches pour un
parkinsonien en fauteuil roulant mais on
a des sous pour changer de sex qu'est
vous répond à çaah je réponds que
toujours pareil faut pas hiérarchiser
les souffrances etencore une fois pour
rien et que il y a des personnes trans
aussi qui se suicident on est dans on
est en 2023 on est dans un pays
développé dans une société moderne et la
santé mentale
ça mais malheureusement il a une étude
qui vient de sortir pour dire que les
personnes qui ont changé de sexe ont
plus de tendan suiciire qui n pas
changé il des chiffres qui sont pas bon
excusez-moi
o moi j'ai jamais j'ai jamais eu de
d'idée
suicidaire j'assume tout ce que j'ai
fait voilà quoi mais quand tu es dans le
dans dans dans le tourbillon c'est c'est
mort c'est c'est c'est courant ce genre
d'addiction et de dérive dans le monde
du du sport professionnel ou pas
apparemment maintenant j'en fais partie
euh les entraîneurs ou les sportifs
après leur carrière font tous une petite
dépression on va dire et moi ça fait
longtemps que ça dure
vraiment quoi dépression vous la
matalisez comment ça matalise comment
votre dépression c'est vous arrivez pas
je pleure j'en veux à la terre entière
pourquoi vous envoyz quoi je sais pas
parce que j'ai tout gâché tout ce que
j'ai tout ce que j'ai construit je l'
gâché racontez-nous c'est quoi vous
aviez construit quoi une belle vie quoi
une belle maison sur les bords de
Marne une vie de famille même si j'ai
pas d'enfants vous tiez marié non non
non vous aviez une compagne am voilà qui
et voilà j'ai tout je pense que j'ai
tout détruit même encore aujourdi
comment vous avez tout détruit parce que
quand on vous écoute au début de du
témoignage on se dit bon c'est un mec
qui fait un peu la fête voilà qui s
entraîné et puis quand il av fini ses
combats il faisait la fête mais quand
vous dites j'ai tout détruit comment
vous avez tout détruit qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé parce que j'ai pas été
entouré j'étais j'étais un assisté de la
vie j'étais à DP à l'époque
ouaisîn voilà tuasas tu as 16 ans tu as
mal tu as mal au cheveux bah tu vas chez
le coiffeur en face tu as mal au ventre
tu vas chez le médecin et après tu te
retrouves dans la vraie vie comme
j'appelle ça à payer des factures à
payer un loyer et quand tu as de moins
en moins les moyens tu gagnes plus
d'argent voilà moi je suis fonctionnaire
à la ville de Saint-Quentin faites quoi
maintenant je suis ambassadeur des Jeux
Olympiques pour la ville fa que je me
déplace dans les collège lycée et vous
gagnez combien vous maintenant bah je
suis je suis non on parle pas d'argent
j'aime pas ça d'ord mais mais je gagne
voilà je suis fonctionnaire donc voilà
quoi c'est quoi c'est 1700 € alors
qu'est-ce qu'est-ce qui a fait
qu'aujourd'hui vous dites vous avez tout
perdu c'est quoi votre rapport aux
femmes parce que je sais que mon rapport
femm que moi je suis dans le c'est tout
ou rien c'est j'aime ou j'aime pas je
fais ou je fais pas voilà j'ai décidé de
venir là je viens là d'accord j'aurais
pu faire demi-tour avec mon frère
j'aurais dit ramène-moi en fait j'y vais
pas je suis comme ça je je dois être
bipolaire peut-être c'était quoi vos
addictions part l'alcool cé que l'alcool
alcool alcool alcool matin midi soir
ouais matin midi
soirrible je dormais alcool je vivais
alcool je mangeais pas pour avoir assez
de place pour boire ah ouais
ouais ah j'étais à fond ouais c'est je
fais tout je fais rien je bois ou je
bois pas donc aujourd'hui je bois plus
c'est bon pour ma santé qu'estceit
qu'est-ce qui a fait que vous avez
arrêté j'étais
prêt pas eu un déclic un déclic voilà
j'aime ma famille j'aime ma copine que
j'appelle mon
assistante j'aime mes parents quoi j'ai
faire plaisir ouais de que vous l'appz
votre assistante non mais c'est un terme
non c'est c'est notre NRE code c'est le
termeide beaucoup je pense ex à mettre
beaucoup et puis voilà ouais oua on la
laisse dans l'ombre aujourd'hui vous
avez pu mettre de l'argent de côté ou
pas du tout non j'avais une maison à
475000 € ouais sur les bords de Marn bah
voilà quoi comme pro qu'est-ce qui a
fait que vous avez d la vendre parce que
j'ai une séparation difficile et voilà
quoi elle a préféré racheter ma on é de
dessus h d'accord et là aujourd'hui
vous de de l'argent de la maison il il
vous reste quoi de l'argent de la maison
ah rien c'est rien je préférer les
voitures et boire c'est vrai ah ouais ou
vraiment quoi les voitures vous fa vous
faisiez plaisir les voitures ça les
voitures vous faisiez plaisir non mais
c'est un délire je je me gratifie quoi
là je suis là je me gratifie je suis
content je bois plus tu m'invites boou
c'est ça B ouais non mais c'est fou
parce que c'est vrai que c'est c'est
c'est c'est c'est drôle de c'est
intéressant d'entendre témoignage de
Jérôme parce que c'est c'est fou parce
que moi je voilà on connait tous et
c'est vrai que nous dans notre tête on
se dit et je suis sûr que les
téléspectateurs c'est pareil eux ils ont
une vie de fou c'est incroyable ils
doivent prendre beaucoup d'argent et ils
doivent être et aujourd'hui toi tu as la
vie DEAS la vie de voilàas une vie je
voilà je sais que vous avez reçu voilà
je suis pas dehors j'ai un
toit j'ai un boulot j'ai maintenant j'ai
une stabilité j'avais un problème
l'alcool ou et voilà quand tu une
maladie hein c'est une maladie chronique
ça ne se soigne pas ouais ça se guérit
pas c'est ve dire que demain je peux
rechuter ah vraiment vous en avvez
conscience bah il faut être pourquoi
j'ai réussi dans le sport parce que je
suis objectif je suis entier je me
remets en question je sais pourquoi je
gagne je sais pourquoi je perds ou je
sais pourquoi mon mon boss il est gentil
avec moi ou pas mais aujourd'hui est-ce
que vous essayez d'éviter complètement
de voir des gens qui boivent à côté de
vous sortir non du tout ah du tout même
quand il y a des gens qui boivent à côté
de vous quand vous allez faire vous ça
vous fait rien j'étais même déçu que
dans la loge il y a pas de champagne non
c'est vrai il y a pas d'alcool juste
pour pas le boire ouais juste pour dire
à mon frère tu as vu c'est de la merde
ça et vous dites que si vous rebuvez
vous mourrez non mais ça c'est ça c'est
une image c'est il y a pas de
médicaments qui font que tu bois tu vas
mourir enfin ça serait trop bien et trop
facile
si je rebois ça veut dire que je sais
que c'est la fin pour moi on pourra je
pourrais pas pas me relever une deuxième
fois vous avez peur dans les cannibaux
je serai mort vous avez peur de reboire
ouais non je non non j'ai peur de la vie
surtout j'ai peur de dem main déjà et de
reboire non non non ça c'est dans ma
tête c'est une conviction votre papa
votre papa il vous dites que votre papa
il il est parti parce qu'il était
alcoolique ce que vous avez dit il était
alcoolique il était sous Tiel il vivait
à Nice on l'a retrouvé devant sa chambre
d'hôtel avec des
bleus et j'avais plus trop de nouvelles
parce que quand il m'appelait c'était
tout le temps pour de demander de
l'argent à un moment je lui ai dit stop
prendre mes nouvelles d'abord et on l'a
retrouvé comme ça après on a fait une
autopsie on l'a remonté chez nous dans
le Nord à à Saint-Quentin et finalement
il avait le cancert du
pouon c'est ça qui vous a marqué aussi
peut-être je sais pas non moi je suis un
je suis un je suis un effronté enfin je
suis handicapé moi déjà j'ai le syndrome
de polande c'est une maladie rare je
serai une femme j'auraiis qu'un sein
j'ai qu'un PEC là d'accord et je suis
qu'une main euh une main de canard qui
était collé on m'a opéré cette fois
voilà champion de boxe j'étais voilà je
je suis pas il y je suis voilà je suis
dans les valides non mais votre histoire
est folle pour ça c'est vraiment c'est
une histoire incroyable je vais écrire
un livre un deuxième parce que j'en ai
déjà fait c'est vrai que son histoire
est folle c'est vrai que vous êtes
handicapé
ça c'est vrai et il est champion
champion de
boxe je sais que vous avez
financièrement vous avez pris des
crédits à la consommation ce que vous
avez déclaré
aussi ça vous avez 30000 € de dette à pr
c'est la facilité voilà engranage c'est
ça 30000 € de
dette c'est comme ça c'est c'est c'est
le prix à payer pour mes conneries c'est
quoi vos conneries d'avoir acheté des
trucs qui me servaient à rien c'est quoi
ces
trucs des conneries des quoi dites-moi
j'ai hte de le dire il y a aucune honte
pas des perroquets des voilà quoi vous
avez fait des un crédit pour acheter un
perroquet c'est ch
ch 100 à quel moment vous dites je vais
faire un crédit pour faire pour acheter
un perroquet c'est génial ça c'est la
maladie du malaimé c'estation vous a dit
je va un PER acheter les gens ah ouais
un perroquet combien ça coûte un
perroquet cher euh le har Runa il m'a
coûté 2008 et le hara
African celu il reste à bamaco et puis
le voilà quoi le gris du gabon c'est
2005 ouais vous Chiha vous avz vous
aviez pas l'argent pour acheter un
perroqué vous AZ achet un pour les
animaux ouais je trichéis un peu sur mes
revenus salaire on va dire ah ouais
auprès de qui bah de
qu même la banque la banque prête he
ouais et vous avez acheté quoi comme
truc
fou non c'est bon franchement mais c'est
maintenant c'est c'est ça qui est
intéressant aussi parce que je pense que
ce que vous allez dire ça va parler à
beaucoup de monde qui nous regarde et
ils vont se dire on va pas faire les les
M les mêmes bêtises parce que vous en
parlez vous en parle très bien et en
fait
vous vous on voit que vous avez
complètement conscience que
vous avez déconné ça moi j'aime bien
quand vous dites mes conneries truc
aujourd'hui ou mais c'est hyper
important pour les gens qui nous
regardent aujourd'hui en direct parce
que comme vous l'avez dit l'alcool c'est
une maladie c'est une addiction très
très c'est très difficile de s'en sortir
et aujourd'hui moi je suis heureux de
vous voir comme ça et d'en parler comme
ça avec autant de détachement parce que
je vous trouve détaché et c'est vrai que
quand vous dites voilà des conneries que
j'ai faites j'ai acheté un perroquet
c'est vrai qu'on a envie de savoir vous
avez acheté quoi c'est quoi
des cinéma des conneries non non non pas
ça je non c'est des VO che des
déplacements justement par rapport à mon
addiction j'ai pas de voiture moi ouais
parce que j'ai pas envie de donner du
danger aux gens ouais ah escinter
quelqu'un ou tu es une famille d'accord
donc je me suis dit j'ai pas de voiture
soit je prends le taxi soit on m'emmène
donc quand je fréquenté du du côté de
Bordeaux ou quoi ah je loué une voiture
la plus belle qui soit quoi et pu ah
ouais quoi non c'est pas des trucs de
ouf mais genre je sais pas 3008 ou non
mais non pas les discret français quoi
français ouais
Citro c'est quoi c'est c'est vous aviez
c'est c'est les les femmes aussi qui
vous ont fait faire des dépenses des
trucs ou pas du tout non mais j'aime
faire plaisir ah ouais faisz plaisir
quoi tous vos potes et tout bah je
rincais tout le monde c'est clair j'aime
par on entend souvent ça chez les
sportifs aussi on entend il rincit tout
le monde voilà c'était çai après quand
vous étiezah quand tu es connu tuas tu
as les passes tu rentres partout ouais
voilà tu il y a la parité mais ça existe
pas quand tu es connu ouais non tu as
pas Besin de Nana tuas 10 mec tues Raon
exactement tu mets des bouteilles ah
ouais la raison c'est vrai vous faisiez
des soirées quoi 2000 € 1000 € 1000 € je
sais pas j'avais pas une notion de
l'argent ah ouais vraiment mais la carte
et puis voilà quoi ah ouais et donc vous
rinciiez tout le monde c'était le
problème c'est j'ai continué de vivre
comme si je gagnais encore cet argent
exactement comme si vous gagnez encore
10000 € mais sauf que vous gag 1008 par
le banquier je lui dis fais-moi une
black ou une gold il me dit attention
monsieur Thomas ouais elle dit jamais
non ouais c'est vrai et notamment a
jamais dit non ah bah arriv à 12000 il
m'a appelé il m'a dit Monsieur Thomas
vous aurez pas fait voler votre carte
non je dis fallait dire oui non c'est
vraou moi j'aimerais savoir aussi votre
rapport parce que vous êtes une énorme
star voilà moi qui suis fan de box si si
bah si des plus gros champions français
je te le dis tu un des plus gros
champions français je connais bien la
box sa aussi d'accord avec
moi as senti comment comment c'est c'est
quoi le le changement avec tous les gens
parce que tu dois avoir plein de gens
autour de toi tu devis avoir tous les
mecs qui te qui te pass la pommade je
suis lucide en fait plus alors déjà pas
grand monde m'intéresser ou et avec la
lucidité il y a encore moins de monde
qui m'intéresse c'est et mais tu as
senti que les mecs voilà les mecs qui
étaient derrière toi tu as senti que tu
avais beaucoup beaucoup de monde autour
de toi et qu' après beaucoup
moins c'est clair quand tu maintenant tu
vas moi il faut que je vois du monde
parce que je suis vachement dans la
solitude mais il faut que je vois du
monde je suis seul mais avec du monde
ouais donc je faut faut que je sorte si
je reste chez moi je suis pas bien ouais
donc que bah tu bois un diabolo fraise
t'intéresse déjà moins de monde ah ouais
donc tu as vite fait le tri en fait
ouais c'est ça et même les mecs que tu
rines plus tout ça tu les vois plus tous
les mecs que tu rinçais à l'époque tu
les vois toujours ou pas ah mais moi
c'est j'ai j'avais pas d'amis j'en ai
encore moins vraiment ouais tu que tu es
entouré de qui aujourd'hui mon
assistante et puis mes frères qui qui
m'ont qui m'ont tendu la main qui m'ont
sauvé la vie surtout c'est vrai ouais
tes frères ils étaient là quand quand ça
cartonné pour toi ouais ouais ouais ils
ont toujours été là et derrière ils ont
vu est-ce qu'il un moment il y a un de
tes frères ou quelqu'un de ta famille ou
un de tes proches qui t'a dit Jérôme je
crois que tu es en train de partir en
cacahuète et que tu vas ils ont jamais
osé me le dire parce que s je me braque
ouais c'est ça et je les vois plus ouis
tu es comme moi toi h ouais je me braque
vite donc je me braquais quoi et puis un
jour je j'appelais j'ai dit faut venir
là ah ouais tu as eu parce que tu es es
extrêmement fier tu as eu tu as eu le tu
t'es dit là je peux plus parce que si je
les appelle pas ouis j'étais au bout
j'étais au bout des choses tu leur as
dit quoi tu les as appelé ah j'ai dit il
faut venir ils t'ont dit il faut venir
ils sont arrivés tout de suite il m'ont
vidé le frigo mon petit frère qui est
infermier m'a dit demain matin je vais
faire une prise de sang ouais il est
venu il m'a enfermé chez moi
ensuite euh il a revenu à 11h il avait
déjà euh il fallait euh peut-être 6 à 8
mois d'attente il m'a dit voilà je t'ai
pris un rendez-vous est-ce que tu veux y
aller j'ai dit oui et la femme m'a
tellement mis en confiance que moi je me
suis fait euh entre guillemets interné
par mon par mon enfin c'est moi c'est
mon souhait c'est pas mes frères ouais
et je dit il faut que je me soigne
tuétais pas adcte au jeu aussi ouais
mais ça c'est le poker mais c'est tout
le monde que tu me dis pas tout là
beaucoup là a mais sin ça va être long
il y aura plus assez de temps non mais
poker c'est pas tout le monde tuas aussi
tu jou au poker tu ouais parce que je
suis je suis Velard je suis comme
j'étais dans la boxe ouais j'ai ce vis
qui fait que j'aime les choses qui pe
que je peux pas limite toucher tu
préfères ta vie d'avant ou ta vie de
maintenant je sais pas là maintenant que
je suis du site je suis triste quoi je
suis tu es triste là plus l'alcool pour
m'alcooliser pour oublier que je suis
triste maintenant tuas maintenant tu as
une fiancée tu as des frères qui
t'entourent tu as un métier pourquoi tu
es triste comme ça je sais pas j'ai
toujours été triste même quand tu étais
champion du monde
ouais ça vous savez il il y a pas
longtemps j'ai contacté un prur un
prur vendre mes médailles parce que çag
qu quoi c'esti sérieuxas tu as appelé
quelqu'un pour vendre tes médailles ça
dégoûte pourquoi ça te dégoûte c'est
incroyable que c'est comme si j'étais au
chômage et je regardais mon mon
baccalauréat sur le mur encadré j'ai le
même sentiment tu veux plus voir ces
médailles tu veux plus voir ces images
de toi quand tu es étaéis champion j'ai
plus rien de chez moi chez moi j'ai plus
rien des jeux j'ai tout donné tout mais
tu en es pas fier quand même de d'avoir
été champion du monde tu en es fier
normal c'était mon job c'est pas normal
la box ça vous PL plus pas normal vous
regardez plus les combats tout ça ça
vous intéresse non non très peu parce
que j'ai encore mon frère qui boxe ouais
mais non ça m'intéresse pas je suis
Jérôme c'est c'est incroyable ton
témoignage vraiment très content de
t'avoir rencontré en tout cas incroyable
il faut vraiment faut pas que tu sois
triste tu es un immense champion il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de gens qui sont fier
de toi et de ce que tu as amené à la
France et donc vraiment tu te rends pas
compte je pense que tu minimises
beaucoup ce que tu as fait et quand tu
dis boxer c'est mon métier on peut boxer
il y a plein de boxeurs qui sont pas
champions du monde je te dis il y en a
moins qui sont il a il a moins qui sont
champions du monde que des mecs qui sont
et surtout des des Français il y en a en
a peu éta tu es un immense champion je
te le dis au contraire pour moi toi tu
dois que profiter de la vie et te dire
voilà ce que j'ai fait c'est incroyable
et aujourd'hui je veux profiter
autrement et vraiment tu es tu es un mec
exceptionnel voilà merci tu un
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
énorme